mientras el kremlin dice estar abierto a
la diplomacia cubre también los otros
escenarios las imágenes satelitales
muestran un aumento continuo de las
tropas rusas en tres flancos ucranianos
el campamento del ejército ruso de kursk
se encuentra al norte de la segunda
ciudad más grande de ucrania un número
cada vez mayor de vehículos blindados se
reúne cerca de la carretera que conecta
las ciudades
más al oeste en belarús se están
apareciendo helicópteros rusos a sólo 25
kilómetros de la frontera ucraniana
estos tanques
aerotransportados suponen una ventaja
estratégica para los rusos dado el
terreno pantanoso otro acontecimiento
clave se encuentra al sur de ucrania el
número de soldados y las instalaciones
están aumentando en la península de
crimea con la llegada de buques rusos al
mar negro pero los aliados de ucrania
también incrementan su presencia han
llegado a polonia 40 vuelos
estadounidenses con 1000 soldados
mientras que las tropas y los vehículos
se preparan en las bases de la otan en
rumanía a éstos los suministros y
equipos que llegan directamente aquí a
algunos civiles incluso se están
entrenando para tomar las armas en caso
de que se produzca la invasión los que
saben qué hacer desde los primeros
minutos de una guerra tienen los medios
para salvar sus vidas y las de sus seres
queridos
eeuu cree que una invasión podría
producirse en cualquier momento alemania
ha sido criticada por su cautela a la
hora de ayudar a ucrania militarmente
mientras que francia lidera los
esfuerzos diplomáticos
moscú podría estar esperando que al
mantener la presión a lo largo de sus
fronteras sea suficiente para apretar
los botones entre los miembros de la
otan y hacer que la alianza se desmorone